[موسيقى]
معركه سوليدار وحسم يكرر سيناريوهات معارك
سابقه تحاول روسيا تاكيد اعلانها بسيطره
المطلقه بعد طول قتال ترد كيف بنصف نفيا
وتقول ان قواتها ما زالت تقاتل دفاعا عن
المدينه في مقابل الميداني يتزايد قلقوا
اوكرانيا من رياح غزو بيلاروسيا تصفيف
بالخطا الاستراتيجي وقع لا تردوا بلا
روسيا سوى باعلان رفع جاهزيه بعضه وحداتها
وياتي الرد من موسكو بالتحذير من ان اي
غزوه او اعتداء اوكراني سيواجه برد جماعي
في التفاصيل اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
سيطره قواتها بشكل كامل على مدينه سوليدار
شرقي اوكرانيا ليله الماضيه وقالت الوزاره
ان الخطوه ستسمح بعزل القوات الاوكرانيه
في باخموت وقطع الامدادات عنها ووصفتها
بانها خطوه حاسمه في العمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا وبعيد الاعلان شهاده القوات
المسلحه الروسيه بما وصفته شجاعه قوات
مجموعه فاجنر خلال المعارك بسولدار
من جهته قال متحدث عسكري اوكراني ان روسيا
لم تسيطر على المدينه وان القتال العنيفه
مازال مستمرا مؤكدا ان القوات الاوكرانيه
لا تزال تدافع عن مواقعها في المدينه وكان
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني قد نفى سيطره
القوات الروسيه على سوليدار مؤكدا ان
الوضع في المدينه صعب للغايه لكنه تحت
السيطره وبثت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
صورا قالت انها لتصدي قواتها لمحاولات
تسلل روسيه في بقمت واكدت ان جنودها
يحافظون على مواقعهم في المدينه رغم
الهجمات الروسيه
ونشر مركز الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه وامن
المعلومات في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
مقطع فيديو قال ان الجنود اوكرانيين الى
التقطوه من داخل مدينه سوليدار واكد
المركز ان المدينه لا تزال تحت السيطره
الاوكرانيه وان المعلومات الوارده عن
سيطره القوات الروسيه عليها غير صحيحه